The Joe Rogan experience. All
right. Let me ask you this,
because you're all in the technology. Go
ahead. What do you think about aliens?
It's doesn't seem tech related at all.
Yeah. Um, do you think they exist?
Do you think they've ever
visited here? Oh God, no.
No, I don't think so. I think
they would've destroyed us.
Brilliant. Yeah, but why?
When we visit primitive tribes,
we don't destroy them necessarily.
Like we try to leave them alone.
Do we try,
but we end up destroying him one way
or the other. Anyways, I was a few.
Even when people do for sure. Even when
we try to be nice, it's like, yeah,
look that tribal, let's analyze them,
sent a few photos, let's give them food,
and they nearly die pretty
much. Yeah. There's always that.
There's that image of famous
image of these tribes,
people in Brazil and uncontacted tribe
and they're painted their body paint and
then the arrows drawn at the
helicopter. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah.
Now they know about helicopters and
slowly and surely the freaking house,
the new song, God, yeah. Now they worship.
Any religion can see you think about it.
Imagine if you were an uncontacted
tribe and all of a sudden you saw the
helicopter shows up. Whenever I see a
helicopter show, I freak out in general.
Yeah. In general. You know what I mean?
So like imagine that's, that's insane.
Have you ever been in one helicopter?
Yes. So weird. Right? Right. It's weird,
but yeah, around like, okay,
we're in the sky way. It makes
noise. Absolutely. But no,
I think, um, I don't know
man. I think they would've
destroyed us. They'd be like,
these guys are stupid.
Don't you think it would want to watch
look like if you go to the zoo, right?
You go to the, the chimpanzee exhibit
and you watch them swing around and shit.
People love to watch the chimps.
It's probably one of the most popular
parts of the exhibit and we love watching
them like, oh, look at them, look at them.
And if you could go someplace where
you could wash them in the wild. Yeah.
Like if there was like a Webcam or you
can tune in to the Congo right now,
you would definitely. How do we, how do
we know they're not watching us right now?
Exactly. That's the thing. They
probably are. They probably are,
but wouldn't they just like
watch and observe? So we just,
we don't blow ourselves.
So we would never know that in general
they can live among us. We wouldn't know.
I mean,
I would imagine that if there was a
civilization that's on the cusp of some
major breakthrough as far as artificial
intelligence goes, which is where we are.
Right?
And in many ways I think that we're all
super fortunate to be alive right now.
Absolutely. Because even though this
is a time of incredible turmoil,
it's also a time of an amazing potential
and change. I'm greedy as hell though.
I want to see more. I know I
want to see more. I want to see,
I really want to see a robot uprising.
I, I'm dead serious. What don't I do ask.
I really do.
And I want to be like 90 ish years
old and I want there to be this super
advanced AI robot just to take
over and that shooting shit.
And I also want, I will,
cause Ilan mosque has head,
he'll still be alive because it had
to be in a jar and he'd be like,
I told you so.
I told you a little robot hand.
I told you what I want to say because
it's like, it's the, it's a cool,
it's like Terminator Shit. I'm going to
shit. I want to see that. Why at all.
I want to see the aliens come in and stop
us. Right. And we're about to hit the,
the green switch to turn on
artificial intelligence on what?
The aliens to come down with their little
legs greenhand hand go, hey, hey, hey. No,
no, no, no. They weren't. They were this,
the robot gave this dynamic. Yeah, it's,
it's wrestling with him, right? Yeah.
It's going to grab your Dick like that.
I might like it.
You're going to be beating off that
things gonna come and let me help you.
But the thing is,
what's,
what's stopping that from not wrapping
around his neck and just crushing it.
There's nothing stopping it.
If you get hacked,
think about the same people that
helped you make your Tesla work, right?
They're going to hack
into this fucking thing.
It's going to run right through your
walls. Skynet, it's going to eat your dog.
If you've seen the ones that flip they,
they didn't have them on trap pieces
like Cirque de Solei actually,
have you seen the part where they actually
beat the robots and less like, yeah,
you know what my favorite
part of that is? Well, they,
they beat the robots to find
out the robots fall over,
right? Kick them and shit.
Hida released a statement saying it's
not cool. You can't do the robot.
Get involved in everything. You know what
I mean? It's not cool. Wait, how about,
how about a robot coalition should
be a robot coalition. We're like,
we stand with robots to say, listen, we
built these things but we can't hit them.
Like, let me ask you this.
Here's the real question.
If you're 90 years old and you're still
lucid in your put, your body's failing,
you've got and your
knees are gone and your,
your hip's bad and your back
hurts all the time and your,
your shoulders are all torn apart. You
can't pick things up and they say, rich,
we can download your consciousness,
not this into this artificial body.
It's like you,
if you were Anderson Silva when he
was 30 years old, Black Mirror Shit.
Yeah. They give you the super
powerful body, right? It's, it's,
you're going to feel it just like that,
but now you're going to be like a super
elite athlete and it's going to be you
and we'll put your consciousness or
you can just go to black and see what
happens in the afterlife. He had to just
let, let this 90 year old body dies.
The silliest question ever.
You're going to take the course.
I would shake it bird in
the hand, right? Yeah.
What's APP to let my might be bullshit,
right? I can just myself right now.
When you do that, fuck yeah. Fuck
yeah. If you want to do it right now.
I'm not even at 90 well I think
that's how they're going to get us.
I think slowly but surely they're going
to replace parts like there's already
amazing,
um,
artificial hands that you're creating
and you know limbs that are articulating
rems. He's a thing. Would you want one of
the limbs that looks like a human limb?
Would you want like a robotic limb?
I can terminate her.
I don't want to terminate her limb for
sure. What'd you for sure. I want to,
you want to stare at me?
But what if it was a nice and soft?
Do you think we're close to Robo cop then?
Like would that be maybe the first,
first step? Yeah, that's probably right.
They'd probably going to
do that with like soldiers.
Chefy all the money's in the military.
Yeah, they'll drop the skeleton.
Drop 10 billion on that.
I met social robots,
I saw was at Pachanga casino at the mall.
It's the most ridiculous thing I've
ever weird. I'll fuck that thing up.
The one in the middle, the one in
the middle. I want. So like I said,
I put my hat on it and it said freaking
out. They get mad at you. Yeah.
It just that it's going around
in circles. I would, if it had,
I wish it had a gun on it. Oh No.
Then people will take it seriously.
Well that's the worry
about those dog things.
Those dog like robots that they just
put guns in those motherfuckers.
That is an episode of Black Mirror
episode. No, I didn't see that one. Yeah,
it's called heavy metal. Really? One of
the best episodes. This lady's run out,
the spoiler alert. This ladies running
from these robots had dogs not to have,
I wrote it on something. The dog
looks like one of those things. Yeah,
I gotta check that out.
Yeah.
And it has potential like actual
real technology that it's using.
So like it's not outlandish things
about black mirror. Everything is, yeah,
that could happen. That's
100% but yeah, even a whole,
the thing where they implant memories
and you like live this crazy fake life.
Right. That's all that's on
the horizon. So you know,
the interesting part about Black Mirror
is that there's a pro and a con to
everything.
So there was a,
an episode where a woman wanted to
keep better track of her daughter.
So she implanted that ship so she could
see whatever her daughter sees, right?
Then her daughter got older and older and
she started to see some wild shit that
the kid was doing. Right?
But then to your example,
what would be the downside of putting my
consciousness in someone with a jacket
and like ripped body? Well,
the downside would be,
would you even really be a human anymore
or would you be some sort of a thing
that we've created that keeps your
brain alive? Right? But who cares?
Who does care? Yeah.
Well, here's the thing.
Would you want to live
a whole nother life?
Like how much time do you want in this
fake body? Do you want to be a mortal?
Do you want to keep going forever?
Not Forever now. I mean, what do well,
at 200 years, you know, there's an
old story about that, about a guy,
God dammit.
It's like an old legend about um,
a man who kept killing his son's
in order to live longer like that.
God came to him and told
him if you kill the son,
and he lived to be like
thousands of years old,
but he just had no one around him.
They cared about him and love somebody,
a job in the Bible or something like that,
whatever.
Keep going since from something.
Yeah, I don't remember.
But but point is like when you got
to 200 years, if you said, okay,
I'm going to take this body
and I live in it for 200 years,
200 years I'll be done. That's it. Right?
198 years comes along and you still
like a 30 year old Anderson Silva.
I couldn't do it. You're having
a great time. It's a good point.
But you might be like super wise. That's
the other thing. If you think, if you've,
if you think of how smart a person is,
they keep their shit together and they
become like a mature older man who's just
wise and understands
the way the world works.
He was well read and it really is taking
the time to do the work on themselves
personally. They know themselves better
than they did when they were young.
Foolish man. That's hopefully
most of us as we get older.
But what if you could live 300 years,
how wise would you be done?
My biggest concern isn't
necessarily about being wise.
I think it's about my loved ones cause
like I'll watch, you know what I mean?
Cause you see a lot in 300 if you see a
lot of shit like that's like three wives
actually maybe four six on who knows.
Right.
But like as they pass you'd be like you
have your kids and like your kid will
live to be 80 years old and you're just
like hey you know you your kid a new
body. Yeah that's more tend to
want to go on forever though.
Cause I feel like what's the world gonna
look like in 300 years? Maybe the dope,
maybe it would be the shit.
Maybe people would be,
maybe it would you want it done?
You don't mind.
The most fascinating thing I keep
thinking about is us going to and know Eli
Musk really wants that. Do you want to go?
Would you go? Nope. Why not interested?
It's a one way trip. I know. Look, I
don't want to go to Antarctica. Really?
Fuck what I want to go to Mars.
I don't want to go anywhere
where people can't live.
You go to Utah and the woods and
shoot deers and stuff. People live,
they're beautiful. The streams
and trees. It's gorgeous.
But you were just saying that you don't
like when people come up to you at a
restaurant,
harass you so like you're living alone.
I like being around people though.
That's why I go to a restaurant.
I'm not like in a cave somewhere and
trying to eat. You know what I mean?
I mean there's nothing wrong.
I feel like you would want to do that.
I feel like all this,
all this manly shit that you do,
like men want to just go and just like
light fires and caves and shit and just
like do go on. Mars is
stupid. You can't come back.
That's like going to the shittiest
neighborhood in the known universe.
Even get to one way. Guess what your
name? Oh yeah, we'll live forever.
We'll live on with doesn't
mean Shit. Assholes. No one
cares. No. What's his name?
Lives forever. Hitler. Fuck.